[Music]
triple frontier has just dropped on
Netflix and this action-packed thriller
is getting pretty good reviews across
the board the 120 minute movie has a lot
to unpack from it so I thought I'd put
together a breakdown on the film to
discuss everything that you need to know
about the movie this is full spoilers
ahead so if you don't want to know
anything about the film or its ending
and I highly suggest that you turn off
now don't forget to watch until the end
of the video to hear my review of triple
frontier which is definitely worth
sticking around for
without the way I'm definition and
welcome to the channel where I explain
it so you don't have to after Santiago a
Pope Garcia played by Oscar Isaac
discovers the whereabouts of a
high-profile drug lord named Gabriel
Martin Lauria he reunites with four of
his former Special Forces operatives to
plan a heist it's pretty clear that the
majority of the characters are sick from
fighting for their country and getting
nothing from it and this mission which
they plan to be their last is solely for
personal gain the group are made up of
Tom red fly Davis played by Ben Affleck
who is struggling to pay bills as a real
estate agent William Ironhead Miller
played by Charlie Hunnam who makes ends
meet as a motivational speaker for the
army his brother Ben who is a UFC
fighter and his trainer Francisco
catfish Morales played by Pedro Pascal
whilst predominantly they are retired
the group are struggling to adjust to
civilian life and though they initially
protest Garcia attempting to recruit
them for one reason or another they're
dragged back into the fray it's
basically like when you tell your mates
you don't want a night out but they keep
asking and asking and before you know it
you're lying in the middle of the street
covered in Jagermeister with a woman
named Malcolm
anyway they arrive at the South American
house and discover that these guys
aren't your typical friendly drug
dealers like your ex housemate John but
they're the bad ones that hold
executions in their garden a murder
anyone who would attempt to rob them
Garcia's girlfriend called Jovana
whose brother is in jail after a drug
bust enter
the house and supplies Garcia with
information in exchange for her siblings
release and Garcia reveals to the team
that maybe Chloe the government in like
they originally said isn't the best idea
they say F it and decide to do it anyway
aware that if successful it means that
they won't be able to return to their
normal lives with the help of your bana
Garcia is able to sneak into the
compound and in some stealth scenes that
are reminiscent of Splinter Cell they
take the house and discover that the
money is hidden in the walls it's
wall-to-wall cash literally cuz cuz of
the cash in the war never mind anyway
the group get greedy and tried to take
more cash than they can because DC are
no longer paying Ben Affleck to be
Batman and Lauria ambushes them from his
safe house
shooting William in the process Lorena
is killed and the gods returned to the
house which forces the group to do a
pretty merciless leave no witnesses
cleaner they make it to the LZ
that stands for landing zone in case you
haven't played seven hundred hours of
call of duty and they start extracting
the cash they drop off your vana and her
family with a load of money which is
when she drops the bombshell that they
stole more than the Reyes money and that
more people will be coming after them
over the Andes the helicopter starts
struggling so they have to dump fifty
million dollars but it's not enough and
the gearbox blows on the helicopter
which forces them to make a hard landing
in a farmer's field minus the money it
turns out the farmers field is actually
a drug plantation and after red fly gets
a bit trigger-happy the group have to
bribe their way out of the situation
they traverse the jungle and mountains
making it rain along the way the group
then eventually end up burning a lot of
the money to keep warm and similar to
Pablo Escobar it becomes pretty clear
that it was never really about the money
for these guys the entire adventure for
them has been about returning to the
life that they felt they had to leave
behind red fly in the film states that
he only feels good when he's got a gun
in his hand and this scene of him
tipping his suitcase full of cash on the
fire showcases that all he cared about
was being back on a mission the one
thing that made him feel any semblance
of normality
things heat up pretty quickly for the
group though when they are shot by
snipers and red fly is killed by a boy
from the farm who had been tracking them
until he could get a clean shot they
learned that the village has people
after them and decide that the only way
to survive is to head through them
chucking away the money into a gorge
they carry red flies body the rest of
the journey and managed to commandeer a
Jeep which leads to a drag race to the
beach the group managed to make it to
the beach and boat and from here they
escape when coming to split the cash
though they realized that it would be
morally wrong to take it when red fly
didn't make it home so they decide to
forfeit their shares and donate the
remaining 5 million dollars to his
family they go their separate ways and
Garcia promises to go and see your vana
in Australia he part ways with William
reminding him to make sure that red
flies family don't forget who he is
William passes him as crumpled up piece
of paper and says maybe you can go and
do something good with it one day
Garcia opens it up and finds that there
are coordinates written there now those
who are confused as to what this means
this is because during the scene when
the group throw away the money
William marked it on the map as the area
will be covered in snow soon it becomes
unlikely that it will ever be discovered
by those who don't have the exact
coordinates quite a smart move and lets
us know that the trip wasn't for nothing
and that ties up the film and sends us
into the credits now on to my review
Netflix original movies are often pretty
mediocre and normally the films only
appear on the platform because the
studio behind them don't have the
confidence to distribute them
theatrically however I thought that
triple frontier was fantastic the movie
could have fallen victim to a number of
cliches but every time I thought that
one would rear its head at the film dive
there it and through another hurdle in
front of the group this is really
gripping cinema that is reminiscent of
films like Sicario 2 and much more and
it still feels unique and original
overall I had a fantastic time with the
movie and right now it stands as one of
the best original films on the platform
everyone performed fantastically and
hopefully one day we get a quadruple
frontier even if that title is terrible
anyway what were your thoughts on triple
frontier and did you figure out more
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my breakdown
of this week's other big release Captain
Marvel which will be linked at the end
this is a channel for people who were
mad into movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]